the raiders picking up their first
preseason win of the season this past
saturday in front of fans at allegiant
stadium 8 sports now kevin martin
joining us with a recap of the win
reaction from fans who were in
attendance for the very first time it
was certainly a big deal kevin yeah you
know preseason wins don't typically hold
much meaning but saturday's 20-7 victory
over seattle wasn't your typical
preseason game it was the first raiders
game at allegiant stadium with fans in
attendance more than 50 thousand fans
were on hand saturday to witness history
as third string quarterback nathan
peterman led the offense going 29-39 for
246 yards and an interception while the
silver max defense held seattle just one
touchdown and while it was clear raider
nation was happy to be back in allegiant
stadium cheering on their squad the team
was just as thrilled to have their fans
in the building
it was great to have the raider fans out
there by the way
kind of numb you know just uh to see the
world coming back together
and to be in this stadium with these
fans again it um
it just warms my heart i thank them all
for coming out and um
you know we we are really really excited
about playing in front of them for the
rest of this year
the raiders now have two more preseason
games both on the road and then they'll
return home for their first regular
season home opener against baltimore on
monday night football on september 13th
kiersten